tenemos una ecuación bastante
interesante por aquí y dice v elevada a
la potencia menos 6 quintos por la raíz
quinta de v es igual a v
elevado a la potencia k para v mayor o
igual a 0 y lo que quiero hacer es
intentar averiguar el valor para acá así
que cuánto vale acá y bueno de nuevo te
encargo que pausa el vídeo ip así puedes
averiguar el valor de acá y te doy una
pequeña pista trata de utilizar las
propiedades de los exponentes bien pues
vamos a trabajarlo juntos y lo primero
que se me ocurre es ser consistente
sobre la anotación que vamos a usar en
nuestros exponentes porque aquí tengo v
elevado a la menos 6 quintos y por aquí
tengo la raíz quinta de v pero sabemos
que la raíz quinta de algo en este caso
la raíz quinta de v
y déjame ponerlo por aquí sabemos que la
raíz quinta de v esto es exactamente lo
mismo que v elevado a la 1 5º estás de
acuerdo y la razón por la que estoy
haciendo esto es debido a que estoy
multiplicando aquí una misma base con
dos diferentes potencias es decir dos
diferentes potencias dv por eso podemos
usar nuestras propiedades de los
exponentes y bueno debido a esto voy a
escribir esta misma expresión pero de la
siguiente manera voy a poner v elevado a
la menos 6 quintos esto que va a
multiplicar a su vez y en lugar de poner
la raíz quinta de v
voy a poner v elevado a la un 5º estás
de acuerdo y esto bueno claro va a ser
igual a v al a camps va a ser igual a vm
elevado a la potencia acá si multiplicas
a v elevada a una cierta potencia
por elevada a otra cierta potencia bueno
pues por las propiedades de los
exponentes sabemos qué va a pasar y si
no puede recordarte por aquí la
propiedad de los exponentes que me sirve
y ésta dice que x elevado a la x x
elevado a la vez esto es lo mismo que x
elevado a la más ver recuerdas así que
observa que aquí tengo la misma base mi
base es v y entonces me va a quedar lo
siguiente me va a quedar v elevado a que
potencia bueno va a estar elevado a la
potencia menos seis quintos y a esto
habrá que sumarle habrá que sumarle más
un quinto es decir tengo a v elevado a
la potencia menos seis puntos más un
quinto y bueno claro esto va a ser igual
a v elevado a la cta y creo que ya
puedes ver bien en dónde va a acabar
todo esto porque esto aquí va a ser
igual bueno pues me va a quedar
vm elevado a qué potencia ahora observan
vamos a sumar estas dos potencias y
cuanto es menos seis puntos más un
quinto bueno va a ser elevado a la
potencia menos cinco quintos o menos uno
estás de acuerdo menos uno y por lo
tanto esto va a ser igual a quién ha
elevado a la cama y ya está porque
entonces podemos decir que camps vale
menos uno
este valor de aquí
vale menos uno esta es nuestra respuesta